>From the class P we now
turn to the class NP.
At the beginning of the lesson I said
that NP is the class of problems
variable in polynomial time.
This is true but
it's not how we typically define it.
Instead, we define NP as the class of
problems solvable in polynomial time
on a nondeterministic Turing machine,
a variant that we haven't
encountered before.
Nondeterminism in computer
science is often misunderstood.
So put aside whatever associations
you might have had with the word.
Perhaps the best way to understand
nondeterministic Turing machines
is by contrasting a nondeterministic
computation with a deterministic one.
A deterministic computation starts in
some initial state, and then the next
state is exactly and uniquely
determined by the transition function.
There's only one possible
successor configuration.
Into that configuration, there's
only one possible successor, and so
on, and so forth, until an accepting or
rejecting configuration is reached,
if one is reached at all.
On the other hand,
in a nondeterministic computation,
we start in a single initial
configuration, but it's possible for
there to be multiple
successor configurations.
In effect, the machine is able to
explore multiple possibilities at once.
This potential splitting
continues at every step.
Sometimes, there might just be
one possible successor state.
Sometimes there might be three or more.
For each press, we have all
the same possibilities as for
the deterministic machine.
The machine can reject,
it can loop forever, or it can accept.
If the machine ever accepts
in any of these branches,
then the whole machine accepts.
The only change to the seven triple
definition of the deterministic
machine that we need to make is to
modify the transition function.
The range is no longer a single state,
tape symbol being red,
direction tuple, but a whole
collection of such possibilities.
The set of all subsets is
often called a power set.
The only other change we need to
make is when the machine accepts.
It accepts if there is any
valid sequence of configuration
that results in an accepting state.
Naturally, it also rejects only when
every branch reaches a reject state.
If there's a branch that
hasn't rejected yet,
then we need to keep
computing in case it accepts.
Therefore, a nondeterministic
machine that never accepts and
that loops on at least one branch,
will loop.